look when President Trump was President  you didn't see crisis after crisis you  just didn't see it can you imagine going  on national TV and saying that with a  straight face so for starters half a  million dead from covet under Trump as  if it's no big deal it's the flu open  everything no masks it's a democratic  hoax and then of course I mean I don't  have an hour but the Ukraine Scandal the  North Korean failure the migrant border  crisis attacking reporters and the  institution of a free press using a  Sharpie to change a hurricane map merely  to make himself look better going to  Puerto Rico after a hurricane not  knowing Puerto Ricans or Americans and  then tossing rolls of paper towels like  their basketballs telling people in his  administration to slow down testing  because too much coveted testing is  making him look bad inciting a riot on  January 6th claiming that an election  was stolen and trying to actually stay  in power to